ich wollte die anfragen von dem
automaten dann sagen meine eindrücke
ich habe die stelle weg geld und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute befinde ich mich nicht in meinen
natürlich bin ich manchmal war sondern
in einer werkstatt 35 leute was wir
machen folge setzte video gesehen
ich habe noch nie hat er mich als
jemanden der einfach unfassbar viel
erfolg bei mädels hatten deswegen zeigt
sich heute wie man einfach jedes mich
herum bekommt jedes einzelne jungs auch
also wenn ihr jüngst könnte auch jung um
bekommen mit diesem mit diesem einen
einfachen krieg den ich euch heute zeige
und der schlüssel quasi zum herzen jedes
menschlichen wesen ist der hiir com mit
dafür ist mein neues geläutet
[Musik]
und es ist so extrem dass die leute
sogar einsteigen und natürlich der
allerersten mitbürger der verein ging es
den ich heute schon abgesteckt hat mit
dem auto ungewollt so einfach geht das
wir stellen heute offiziell gefahr jetzt
heute mit diesen dingen spritze war wie
die leute darauf reagieren die leute
folgendermaßen das ist kein vorteil für
etwas das ist einfach ein ding was bald
jeder kanal kommen wird aber wir machen
heute quasi schon ein kleines preview
musik in meinen ohren heute passt auch
das hier ist der sound der schweizer
plan borini scheint auch partie
bei dem die frauen werden und den
bringen
die straße war auch hier die s line
tiptronic schaltung
genau
vw t2 ist ein buslenker busfahrer seien
rein theoretisch müssen ja auch mal
kämpfen und her problem gerecht
in der fahrschule und er kickte
tankstelle
mal schauen vielleicht finde ich
irgendwie so ein sms oder gps oder gegen
die markant rennen fahren kann
er wird wohl mit dem auto hatten halt
wirklich weniger ernst zu nehmende
gegner auf der straße ab 3
ein kleiner trick
manchmal falle recht wenn leute
6 millionen
ob man das heutzutage doch deutlich ist
mcdrive da war mir direkt mal hin und
und mit frechen eingetragen wie sie den
wagen von allen guten geistern million
jung sagte zu dem auto
hallo ich hätte gerne eine kleine falcon
kleinen schock auf zack und ich wollte
die anfragen lassen von dem auto halten
denn vagen eindruck oder ich hab mich
lieber in lambo r8 oder irgendeine frage
einer ehrlichen meinung wie gut ist das
auto auf einer skala von 1 bis 10 und
frauen aufzureißen
hoppala
da sagen
der bund
rennsport autos entschuldigung wirklich
fragen was sie von dem auto hier
erhalten gut oder auf einer skala von
1-10 und aufbereiten alter eichen hörte
sie fragen was sie von dem auto hide wie
geiger skala von eins bis zehn und mehr
ist aufbereiten 9 allen klar dass nun
alles klar leute wir mal so gesehen das
auto kam bestens an
das ist mein einziger war eigentlich
schon für komplett ausreichend ist wenn
ihr über ich gesagt habe für den video
könnte es auch in die kommentare
blumenschau media und rufe eichenberger
exakt